Hello, everybody, Dr. Cutters. Welcome back to the second section on the stop fighting cancer book.
We talked about why treat the cause in the first section, what we're looking for, that the cause is always always
We're always able to find out what that is. We usually able to find out what that is. In our office, there are we have thousands of test kits
Unfortunately, the only one, sometimes the only one that we cannot find the cause is if it's a chemical toxicity, we can just do not have all the possible chemicals. That could be an exposure.
They're just coming out with more every day. So
In other information that we have on our website and in our back office, there's there's just a ton of information slide presentation similar to this about
toxicity and heavy metal toxicity and how to deal with that. I don't get into everything in this book. It's just not possible. You can feel free to download my other books that get into that even in greater depth.
But in this section of the book, we start looking at some things about what is going on with cancer
The war on cancer that started with President Richard Nixon in 1971 was really begun because there was a epidemic of cancer in our society. There was really a crisis of cancer and at that time, the crisis of cancer was that one out of 21 Americans would experience cancer in their lifetime, personally.
That was significantly higher than it was 50 years prior to that. At the turn of the previous century, it was nearly one out of a hundred people in America would get cancer. And it moved in 70 years to one out of 21. We are in an epidemic crisis.
Richard Nixon signed into law this war on cancer. It was well publicized.
Well, during this war on cancer in the last 25, 35 years, we have moved from one in 21 Americans with cancer to one in 2.5 Americans. We'll get cancer.
If this was a war that we waged with millions and millions, maybe billions of dollars since 1971, we have to face the fact we are dreadfully losing this war.
But he is pouring into the coffers of studies and research and pharmaceuticals. And yet the incidence of cancer is tenfold since the war began.
This is a miserable solution, at least the road that we're currently going down. I am never in this book advocating that you throw everything out from your oncologist.
I am not an oncologist and I do not treat cancer. I take care of patients who come to us regardless of their diagnosis and look for these specific pillars that we're talking about.
What is the cause in the second one? What are we going to do about the cause?
Is there an epidemic of cancer in our society today? Yes, there is. What is the reason why is it increased? Well, there's many, many reasons.
Our environment is constantly changing and getting worse. The advent of GMO foods and chemical additives and flavorings and colorings and estrogens and other hormones added to our food supply.
The degradation of our food supply, even organic food contains exponentially less nutrients than organic food did a hundred years ago.
We are living in a crisis that some of the things are just not changeable. Even if you try to eat perfect and do perfect things, you are exposed to toxins that you cannot run away from.
It's not possible. You can't move to a mountain top and be safe. We have really ruined our environment in many ways that maybe it is a team that is really fixable.
So that we consume more medications in this country that I believe any other country, all other country combined, it is just a state of fact.
We become dependent on pharmaceuticals. It's changing our DNA. We have epigenetic changes in our ability to fight off disease and it's affecting our apoptotic and replication cycles and that's what cancer is.
Simple things have been overlooked. I don't know why. Is it solely a bias of money? We'll kind of dig into that a little bit. Why is vitamin D not pushed as much as it should be?
The president of Harvard Medical School a few years ago came out and said vitamin D is, I'm quoting him loosely, vitamin D is the most powerful drug against cancer that we have.
He called it a drug vitamin D is actually a horrible that's produced in your body and it is a wonderful benefit against cancer.
Why is diet not pushed? I cannot tell you how many patients come in my office and tell me that their oncologist said that diet has nothing to do with cancer.
Are you living with your head in a hole somewhere? I just don't understand. We're going to address in this section, should I do chemo?
Is that the right thing to do? I'm not going to say that it's the wrong thing to do, but there are certain things that you want to ask yourself before you undergo that.
There's benefits of chemo, there's benefits of surgery and there's benefits of radiation and I've encouraged members to look at that and keep that on the table.
But without doing some alternative things to stabilize your body, increase your immune system and help detox those poisons, it's statistically not a great endeavor.
Also in this section, we're going to start digging through the next step.
So our first two pillars, we have to uncover the cause always with cancer, we need to uncover the cause with any disease.
Secondly, how are we going to get rid of that cause?
An example would be if the cancer of my cancer was caused from H. Pylora, H. Pylora as a bacterial infection, it is the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide.
It's a major cause of esophageal cancer and colon cancer and many other cancers.
So if that is the cause of my cancer, we want to eradicate H. Pylora in our body and there's some extensive things to do for that.
So we want to look at that. What is the cause? How are we going to fix that cause before we move on to the other steps?
I hope you enjoyed this section, know that we'll be praying for you and just be praying for wisdom for you too.
Always if you have questions, feel free to contact my office and I'll see you at the next section.